3000 exhibitors some 20,000 new products
all designed to delight and thrill about
150,000 people will come through the
Consumer Electronics Show of 2014 this
is just a taster of what they can expect
over the next week with the plan by the
industry is to show what the future will
look like and maybe persuade us to spend
some money as well there are more than a
dozen categories but all of the focus
really is on just three smartphones
wearable technology and things like this
television sets the size of a small
London flat and the interest in these
things is growing all the time with
resolution of 11 million pixels 105 inch
screens the big question is whether the
content is there what the streamers and
the broadcasters are going to do to
provide images for extraordinary pieces
of kit like this and crucially what
Apple is going to do as well smartphones
are getting bigger and faster their
molding to the shape of our face they're
even self-healing repairing those
annoying little scratches that they get
on the back they're communicating with
light emitting rays and smartphones lead
us to this issue of wearable technology
those devices on our wrists that tell us
all about our lifestyles the sales pitch
for a lot of these devices is about
physical fitness making them
indispensable in the modern world and
it's all part of this connected life
Theory the Internet of Things as they
call it that our devices speak to the
Internet a run by the internet and that
that's the future it raises questions of
course about data security whether we
need these devices whether we can afford
them the people here are determined to
show us that we do and this is all the
future